[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called bullying in
schools we're going to discuss the
causes consequences and strategies to
combat bullying in educational
institutions my name is AA and I'll be
your host today bullying in schools is a
serious issue that can have a profound
impact on students mental and emotional
wellbeing schools should have
anti-bullying policies in place to
address the prevent this
Behavior bullying in schools can have
various underlying causes which may
include social dynamics bullying can
often arise from the complex social
interactions and hierarchies among
students those seeking power or status
May Target others perceived as weaker or
different lack of aess students may not
fully understand understand the impact
of their actions or the harm caused by
bullying they might they might not be
aware of the consequences of their
behavior Behavior peer pressure some
students May engage in bullying to
conform to peer groups or because they
fear becoming targets themselves if they
don't
participate family background
experiencing bullying or aggressive
behavior at home can lead to some
students replicating these actions in
school settings
lack of supervision in equate
supervision by teachers and School staff
can create an environment where bullying
goes and checked cultural factors
cultural norms are stereotypes that can
uh influence how students perceive and
treat others potentially contributing to
bullying cyber bullying the rise of
technology has introduced a new form of
bullying where students use digital
platforms to harass and intimidate their
peers so addressing buling in schools
requires a comprehensive approach that
involves students teachers parents and
the school Community this approach
should focus on prevention awareness and
crear
peers so addressing bullying in schools
requires a comprehensive approach that
involves students teachers parents and
the school Community this approach
should focus on prevention awareness and
creating a supportive inclus uh
inclusive environment for all uh
students
bullying in schools can have several
consequences both for the victims and
the perpetrators as well as for the
school Community as a whole here are
some of the
consequences the first one is emotional
and psychological effects for the victim
bullying can result in emotional
distress anxiety depression love
selfesteem and even sdal thoughts these
effects can loss into adulthood the
second one is the academic impact act
victims of bullying often have
difficulty concentrations in school
leading to decreased academic
performance they may avoid attending
school altogether the third one is
physical health bullying can lead to
Fitness victims might withdraw from
social activities in France leading to
to a sense of isolation and
loneliness and the fifth one is um
long-term effects bullying can have long
lasting effect in including a higher
risk of mental health issue difficulties
forming relationships and the potential
for becoming bullies themselves in the
future the sixth one school climate
buling can negatively impact the overall
School climate creating an atmosphere of
fear and
hostility it's crucial for schools and
communities to take a proactive approach
to prevent bullying and provide super
for victims this includes implementing
um promo promoting empathy and respect
and fostering a safe and inclusive
environment for all
students combating bullying in
educational institutions requires a
multifacted approach involving students
teachers parents and the community here
are some strategies to address and
prevent bullying educational programs
Implement and de bullying programs and
curriculum that raise awareness about
the negative impacts of bullying can
teach empathy and conflict resolution
scals teacher and staff training provide
training for teachers and School staff
on recognizing preventing and addressing
bullying they should be equipped to
respond effectively to
incidents role modeling adults in the
school environment should serve as
positive role models demonstrating
respect and empathy in their
interactions consequences for bullies
ensure that there are consequences for
bullying Behavior which may include con
uh conseling disciplinary actions and
involving law enforcement in sever
causes causes celebrate positive
behavior acknowledge and celebrate
positive behaviors and act of kindness
promoting a culture of respect and
empathy preventing and addressing
bullying in schools requires a
collaborative effort from all
stakeholders to create a safe and
inclusive learn learning environment for
students preventing addressing bullying
in schools requires a collaborative
effort from all stakeholders to create a
safe and inclusive learning environment
for
students so bullying is a harmful
Behavior with one person or a a group of
individually repeatedly mistreat
intimidate or harm another person
physically verbally or emotionally it
can have serious and long lasting
effects on the victim's wellbeing if you
or someone you know is experiencing
bullying is essential to seek help from
a trusted adult
or um a
teacher in some tragic causes bullying
can lead to suff IM um in rare instance
instances it may contribute to a person
decision to harm themselves or in the
worst cases lead to Suicide this is why
bullying is taken very seriously and
there are anti-bullying campaigns
support system and Mental Health
Resources in place to prevent such
outcomes it's crucial to intervene and
provide help to both victims and Bullies
to prevent such extreme consequences and
to create a safe and supportive
environment for everyone so I'm going to
say if you or someone know is struggling
with the effects of bullying seek help
from a mental health professional or um
trusted
adult um certainly here's some
additional inform information about
bullying types of bullying bullying can
take various forms including physical
hitting pushing um rable for example
name calling teasing um relational uh
spreading rumors social exclusion and
cyber bullying that is a harassment
through harassment through digital um
devices long-term consequence victims of
bullying can experience long lasting
emotional and psychological effects such
as anxiety or depression
um the other one is the Online safety
cyber bullying is a growing concern it's
vital for individuals parents and
Educators to educate themselves and the
young people about Online safety privacy
settings and responsible digital
Behavior efforts to combat bullying
require a multifaced approach involving
uh schools communities parents and
students working together to create
environments we all IND indviduals are
treated with respect and
kindness how to stop bullying even if
there is no uh physical contact between
a bully and their target people who are
bullied can may carry the emotional
damage of what they experien for the
rest of their lives you can also work to
raise awareness among raise awareness
among your your peers and learn about
the different ways that you can ask for
help for example um walk away if the
situation seems treating or dangerous is
best to get away from the body even if
it's not dangerous situation remember
that you don't have to listen to
[Music]
someone